well i consider myself to be an optimist
and not one considering a retreat but
after some of these uh maps that i've
seen up on the on the board on
particularly the uh
the water table map down in worcester
square i'm starting to think about maybe
moving
um
so
you know we've explored quite a range of
topics and scales and i'm now going to
take you down to a kind of regional and
local scale
and discuss ecologically based land use
planning and site-level green
infrastructure
focused on mitigation and adaptation
strategies
so we know that coastal communities face
a precarious future
sea level rise
in increased storm surge events
intensities frequencies we've heard all
about it
you know nearly 1 in 10 persons living
are living now in low elevation coastal
areas and the predictions are that
that's going to increase over time so we
know we have these issues
there's a lot of money invested in these
in these zones as the senator was
mentioning what are we going to do
given the private property and highland
values as well as the infrastructure
some of it aging
along along the heavily urbanized u.s
eastern seaboard the challenges are
actually quite complicated and uh and
they're the kinds of risks and and
concerns that keep people up at night
so
what i'm trying to do with through my
work bridging ecological research and
urban design is to kind of have a sort
of back and forth and
a kind of feedback between scientific
investigation scientific input but also
action-oriented planning practice and
try to communicate that through a local
level uh kind of collaborative effort
both that builds on education and on
communication and on
site specific local knowledge and
concerns
one of the things that historically
has been a focus is this issue of
managing risk
a problem-solving approach really
that's often reactionary
the repetitive loss properties is one
example of this kind of concern where
your
repeat property loss
there's an idea let's spend money on
that let's try to solve this issue i'm
going to kind of present an alternative
to that part of it is shifting into an
idea of creating resilience and uh and
kind of interdisciplinary um building an
interdisciplinary innovation and and and
also
considering the potential options for
development of
infrastructure along these tough zones
so if you look at the bottom the
sikorsky airport area you can see what
happens over time
the dark blue is um high confidence in
the sea level rise less confidence in
the lighter blue and as you can see the
green and red there's some areas that
are might that are constrained in terms
of migration potential other areas where
there's potential for migration keep in
mind that
along long island sound we have a lot of
existing tidal marsh conditions and
those tidal marshes are critical or have
have been identified as valuable in
terms of wave attenuation
and control of some of the flooding
events and so part of the question is
what do we do about these tough these
intertidal landscapes that are often
placed between development and
infrastructure and so they're caught
between the forces of topographic
constraints and rising tide
how can we actively accommodate these
factors given the title marsh conditions
are so critical and also for nursery
habitats for species that are that are
supporting fish fisheries and tourism in
long island sound
the long island sound stewardship
initiative is an interesting has an
interesting task ahead of them they're
looking after
i think 33 stewardship sites
all of them
pretty much low lying most of them
low-lying so the question is over the
next 80 years what should their planning
mission be for land that uh in
many parts parcels of land that are
essentially predicted to be underwater
over time how do they manage for that
what do they think about do they shift
their agenda into an alternative maybe
thinking about as they are now starting
to think about local communities and the
adjacent conditions
so coastal cities and towns in my
opinion will likely be forerunners of
climate change adaptation and mitigation
because people live there people are
concerned there's money being spent
there's potential for innovation
and this is an image of guilford looking
at 2080
sea level rise and identifying some of
the critical areas in orange that are
existing on site
so
it was mentioned before that i've been
working with guilford in the nature
conservancy on the coastal resilience
plan so i have a fair number of uh
images from that site
and however uncertainty and severity and
frequency of climate change impacts as
well as limited financial resources
limited regulatory scope of local
governments the unequal distribution of
risks
the uneven understanding and
interpretation of impacts and
adaptations
adaptation options and differing values
of citizens experts institutions and
decision makers
they all challenge local adaptation
efforts
so working with coastal communities one
thing that i've realized as
as
tony has mentioned several occasions is
that climate change is a complex wicked
problem as we like to call it so i uh i
thought i'd make a couple graphs for
today's lecture because i predicted that
some of the uh there wasn't going to be
too much um kind of
uh you know
well i thought it was the last person i
wanted to keep everyone awake so
as you can see there's an xyz access
looking at the kind of complexity of
local scale issues all the way down to
household neighborhood institutional
level and thinking about issues over
time the kind of legacies that are
already in place for example the amtrak
line
maybe the amtrak line will end up being
actually a plus with sea level rise for
certain areas because it's actually
essentially an embankment along the
coast
on the other hand it creates all kinds
of pockets of flooding where you have
egress issues for neighborhoods so
there's a there's a also a negative
then you're thinking about watershed
conditions local scale all the way to
larger scale with ron's talk about
increased rainfall increased evaporation
there's all kinds of questions about the
existing infrastructure that we have in
place the stormwater infrastructure and
how's that going to perform over time
one of the things that i've noticed with
guilford is the importance or the um
that there are these impounded marsh
systems all along the connecticut coast
that are uh um that have that don't
function as well hydrologically that
often are the problems in terms of flood
events so they end up being uh
problematic at the local scale um but
they're also important fish nurseries
and
areas for resilience for these
communities
so wicked problems we've got as i said
earlier some of these issues in terms of
uncertainty of severity limited
complications in terms of financial
limited regulatory scope unequal
distribution of risks uh uneven
understanding and interpretation risks
and different values of citizens
and you know when as i engaged with
guilford one of the things i also
realized was the the dynamic nature of
the situation itself makes the process
of coastal adaptation challenging so
as you can see here a diagram here uh
if you take the female 100 a 500-year
flood by 2050
that's essentially the same as the the
fema 100 is essentially the same the
same situation so you're getting this
kind of dynamic condition because of sea
level rise
the mapping the fema mapping efforts and
the designation of land types uh the
choices that people are making for where
they purchase the
the
the flood insurance rate maps and the
way that those relate to fema all these
aspects actually make a very complicated
uh situation in terms of information
real estate practices uh
legal issues across the landscape that
are troubling and difficult for local
communities to
um
engage with and react to in a time
timely manner so here's i also put this
um
recent august 15 fema
memorandum
that actually puts a price on both the
um
structures that are acquisition and
structures and elevation of structures
so
historically you'd have to you'd have to
convince uh you know the zoning board to
allow
or to um potentially that that your
property was damaged and to try to get
funding back now they've set a price on
this
um
where where it's uh
the um sorry where originally the
process to prove hardship was was it was
took time if the acquisition of
structure cost now less than 276 dollars
or the elevation cost to raise your pr
your property costs less than 175
dollars
it's uh it's considered
and the structure is in the special
flood hazard zone then the benefit cost
analysis does not exceed
uh does not need to be conducted to
support the project so in other words
there is a there's a this is a useful
document from fema not so easy to find
but what it's saying is if your if your
elevation is lower than these costs then
you can move forward with your and not
go through all the legal challenges that
are there for getting your property um
paid for
so the complexity of coastal resilience
is also tied into the
multi-jurisdictional nature and the
socio-political dimensions between
homeowners federal state and local
governments all working within the
context of this uncertain future
how do we prioritize and simplify issues
and expand partnerships or change
behavioral patterns and learn to
compromise
the sheer magnitude of the risks can
lead to inaction
and what are the roles of the different
levels of government and how can they
interact and how does adaptation look on
the ground in these coastal communities
what does it become
and what do local governments need in
order to as catalysts to move forward
within this context
when we asked the
group in town the guilford board of
selectmen what was the most important
actions needed to protect guilford from
increased vulnerability due to storm
surge and rising sea level and climate
change
67 percent are argued that these were
physical issues so basically
infrastructure let's spend money on
infrastructure to solve these issues but
when we asked what are the obstacles to
effective action regarding coastal
resilience and climate change uh 89 said
there was institutional and societal so
in fact the problems are people and the
institutions that we have in negotiating
that
so i've been working with the nature
conservancy uh the town of guilford
maloney mcbroom uh partly funded through
noaa on the coastal resilience plan
where we're using the tnc's coastal
resilience model which is an online
web-based model tool that's accessible
to anybody and and can essentially give
you some data and information about um
about sea level rise storm surge events
so
and as i've been suggesting in reality
in my mind coastal adaptation requires
negotiation at the local level for land
use changes in this case based on
predictions so you're going to a town
looking at maps of the future and trying
to negotiate or talk about
how to either retreat or accommodate or
modify land use practices
in anticipation of future conditions
so we really uh let's see so we need a
kind of a process of engagement and a
means of building partnership one of the
things that's interesting is by acting
early and guilford is one of these towns
that's kind of been proactive in this
and and taken this information into a
process of engagement with the public
is that they it's possible that they can
create the kinds of management tools and
tee themselves up for um different
various funding options so there is
value i think to pushing this forward
so one of the things i mentioned earlier
was this repeat uh loss um issue so
there's a number of houses in guilford
that have a repeat loss um conditions in
fact with um from the hazard mitigation
plan which was done in 2011 there were
12 houses that were repeat loss
since
sandy it's gone up to 60.
the uh but as we studied uh guilford
more we we felt as if the repeat lost
properties
they provide the most obvious immediate
need but the pers but
we're calling the perception of risk
which is essentially future home buyers
and those living in homes today
their perceived risk of their
neighborhoods uh probably down the line
will actually cause greater uh um
loss in terms of a greater loss to
property and financial value
and this is a good so in other words
this egress where you're um where 130
home homeowners can enter into the
neighborhood the more that that floods
and creates problems in terms of access
to neighborhood their neighborhood that
actually impacts 130 people
whereas the flood events the repeat loss
damages usually impacts a few people on
the coast
so what we're describing now as zones of
shared risk are essentially these areas
for example sacrum's head where you have
the 130
homeowners versus the repeat loss area
which is a few houses along the coast
keep in mind that some of the houses
along the coast in guilford and
elsewhere are very high value and so
they're heavy contributors to the tax to
for in terms of tax base
so i just wanted to give you a scenario
planning for how we start to move
forward on recognizing the zone of
shared risk
this is an area seaside village and
maybe some of you have been to jacob's
beach or the stone hou the stone house
here
um
let's see
and you know one of the things that
people often say at least early on
before sandy was kind of what is this
really going to be like in the future
like what's what what how is flooding
going to look well when you look at
sandy 2012 and you look at
the sea level rise uh anticipations for
2080 it's actually pretty similar
so sandy was actually pretty useful to
illustrate to people what we're we
should potentially expect in the
long-term future um and
in this case it's not exactly about
gathering more accurate uh scientific
data to um to
you know to specify where this is going
to take place exactly it's more about
getting people to buy into the concerns
and the risks that we face
and local
data local information that people trust
and can
see and and maybe even participate in uh
in one sense that can start to shift
this issue of uncertainty from the
scientific community to the public
conscience and
where it really belongs uh we all face
this issue of uncertainty it's not just
the scientists
so we developed a planning process for
this area of seaside avenue which
essentially is mostly marshland so you
have all this marsh conditions you have
this development area here and you saw
the plan before this is all under water
or anticipated to be underwater by 2080
here's the road
there's a bit of a radical plan we
presented it to the public um in july
and and people were actually pretty
enthusiastic about it so
the town owns this parcel here
the first thing to go is really going to
be septic tanks
so what we proposed is developing is
acquiring parcels in the lowest line
area converting this using a cut fill
landscape where you would develop living
shorelines and high points that you
would start to develop communal septic
so you could maintain the other several
of the other houses over the longer term
rather than retreat what we're proposing
is actually to increase recreational
opportunities along the coast and
there's a kind of zone that's slightly
inner from the coast where you can
actually increase development and give
people in that inner area more access to
the coast
and start to recreate the coastal
landscape as a
as a closely adapted
landscape condition so
essentially all along here there's a
there's an amtrak station here there's
an idea for town center south which is a
um transit oriented development so we
encourage this notion of ascending and
receiving zone that you would develop
ascending receiving overlay where people
could uh basically shift uh pro
development into this
inner zone area
and over time you would start to get a
kind of buffer you would develop these
living shorelines not in the water
itself but actually upland using a
ruling rolling easements so that you're
doing lower cost anticipatory
land management landscape alterations
that provide
new types of housing that actually are
situated on living shoreline so that the
houses themselves have easements so that
the town can go through and manage those
living shorelines over time and you
don't walk out of your house and have
your your lawn abutting the wetland in
competition with the the marsh migration
and so over time the uh the idea here is
that we would
jacob's beach would start to move back
and become a kind of recreational
destination beach that also functions as
a
as a shoreline abatement so that this
whole area becomes essentially the the
wetland living troll line combination
that protects the rest of guilford while
also enhancing development increasing
development
and creating a recreational amenity at
the base here
with some alternatives so early on you
do some cut fill landscapes create a
boardwalk system for birding uh develop
living shorelines and this end point
here would either may be maintained as
housing
or would eventually um
potentially be purchased by the town as
destination spots part of the recreation
so okay
that's at a large scale
and i wanted to zoom in briefly and um
and and talk a little bit about sort of
local scale actions as well
um
so one of the challenges we face is is
how to get people involved in
understanding their coasts and
participating in um in kind of an
education process around coastal
adaptation
this was in bridgeport where we were
working with seaside village and it's
both we designed this both as a research
experiment because one of the things we
do need is more data and information and
more monitoring on existing
ecological dynamics on the coast so
using a kind of coupled system with
funding for experimentation but also
funding through epa for sustainability
sustainable community development
we identified the site and bridgeport
that was once wetland it's in the 100
year floodplain
we developed what we called a mapping
effort effort with looking at sub basin
watersheds so we knew the site flooded
quite a bit
and the area where we installed our
system is here it drains this parking
lot so that they have the parking area
now accessible to them we started out
with this idea of developing green
infrastructure across property lines the
goal was to try to say you know if
you're rather than your your neighbor
being the person across the street if
you're if you think of your neighbor as
your sub basement watershed neighbor
and you kind of work collaboratively you
can actually develop green
infrastructure that that can support the
city's uh issues in terms of um in terms
of water their their sanitation sanitary
system is maxed out and they're looking
for ways of holding water upstream so
that they're not having everything flow
all that down at once we developed this
hydrologic distribution system to relay
water to each of these six swales but we
also designed it as a public amenity
with a flood plain grove and six swail
systems and a
park a pathway system that has an
underground perforated pipe for
resilience and increased drainage
capacity here's a hydrologic system that
we designed and we got the community
involved in planting the effort and
actually post sandy because of the the
incredible salt inundation we're back
out replanting because one of the
challenges in these intertidal areas and
these changing landscapes is actually
defined designing a plant palette that
can perform given the the contrast of
dry out and heavy rain heavy rain and
salt conditions
so this is it here this was actually in
the neighborhood during the sandy event
so the the interesting thing is that the
whole neighborhood floods uh
periodically with these major storm
events uh and then this was our site and
through the winter so it floods as well
but it's pretty resilient over time
so these to summarize i just want to say
that we're in this stage now where you
know we're public awareness is growing
big projects are coming down the
pipeline right now we're trying to do
projects that are small scale that are
uh that have that are sort of no fail
that have that are successful so that we
can share these methods and start to
convince
the public of the value of these systems
and how they can work in your
neighborhoods
but over time the idea is to start
expanding these and push them forward
and that's it thank you very much